a push to meant ends us-pakistan
relations in person after clashing on
Twitter Pakistani Prime Minister Imran
Khan has held his first one-on-one talks
in Washington with his erstwhile online
sparring partner
US President Donald Trump the Afghan
conflict responsible for straining those
ties was a key focus of talks Trump
hopes Khan can help broker a peace deal
between the Taliban and the Afghan
government and paved the way to ending
nearly 18 years of US military
involvement in Afghanistan
I have plans on Afghanistan that if I
wanted to win that war Afghanistan would
be wiped off the face of the earth it
would be gone it would be over in
literally in ten days and I don't want
to do that I don't want to go that route
so we're working with Pakistan and
others to extricate ourselves nor do we
want to be policemen because basically
what policeman right now and we're not
supposed to be policemen we've been
there we've been there for 19 years in
Afghanistan Khan who has called for
mutually beneficial ties with the US
since he won Pakistan's general election
last year sounded optimistic there is
only one solution and I feel that I
think we will discuss this it's the
closest we have been to a peace deal and
we hope that in the coming days we will
be able to urge the Taliban to speak to
the Afghan government and come to a
settlement a political solution this
bridge building is a far cry from
relations last year when Trump attacked
Pakistan on Twitter accusing the country
of supporting Islamist militants and
cutting security aid now Trump has held
out the carrot of possibly restoring aid
if this meeting yields results offering
the prospect of better relations between
the two nations okay let's talk about
this some more with twz amo Shawn's
joining us from our Bureau in Bonn
good morning Jamil are we seeing the
beginning of a new era in relations
between the u.s. and Pakistan well I
would say that US
Gaston ties they're improving definitely
but to say that it is a start of a new
era
it would be I think a little premature
at this moment much depends on how is
Lama Bob deals with Washington's demands
regarding peace in Afghanistan and the
issue of terrorism in South Asia
not just in Afghanistan but also in
Kashmir
Pakistan's economy is is in a mess right
now and Islamabad needs the financial
assistance so it is likely that Pakistan
its powerful army would now pay heed to
u.s. demands
okay now during that meeting President
Trump used some very dramatic
rhetoric claiming that the US could wipe
Afghanistan off the face of the earth in
ten days of this reaction to those
statements I think it is the Trump's way
of saying that you cooperate with us
otherwise we have a military option so
it was a message to Han and also to
other players in the region
he has been youing using this carrot and
stick policy in Afghanistan so I don't
think Afghan authorities would like this
a statement it was quite irresponsible
to be honest but I think it was a
message aimed at the Taliban also to
other players in the region
to Han who was sitting next to it okay
now Donald Trump and Imran Khan also
voiced their ambitions for a peace deal
with the Taliban in Afghanistan is that
where the things are heading right now
is that realistic I would not give too
much importance to Khan I think the the
person the Pakistani army calls the
shots the person who was visiting with
Khan his army chief General bagua he has
a lot of influence his army has a lot of
influence on the Taliban so much depends
on the Pakistani military experts say
that the Pakistani civilian government
headed by Khan and the military are on
the same page over a number of security
defense and foreign policy issues but it
we have to see how much influence what
what role the Pakistani military would
like
playing this I think the army chief
Bajwa is key to resolving this conflict
DW use a shampoo chomps thank you very
much for the analysis this morning